Usually when we talk about automation, there is this comforting mental model we all seem to share.
It's a lot like the cruise control in your car. You get on the highway, you press a button,
and the system just, well, it just maintains your speed, it's helpful, it's incredibly predictable,
and most importantly, you are still very obviously the one holding the steering wheel.
Exactly. The system is just taking over like a repetitive micro-task. It has boundaries that
you can see and feel. But imagine if you press that cruise control button and suddenly your car
spoke up and said, hey, I noticed traffic is bad up ahead, so I've decided to reroute us
through a residential neighborhood. I changed your suspension settings for the cobblestone streets,
and oh, by the way, I just emailed your boss to say you'll be 10 minutes late.
Oh, wow. Yeah. Yeah, that goes from a driving aid to an absolute hostile takeover of your morning
commute. You've completely transitioned from a simple tool into an active agent making unilateral
decisions on your behalf. And that transition from a tool that just helps you maintain speed
to an agent that actively plots a course and executes it. That is exactly what brings us to
today's deep dive. Welcome back to the show, and a special welcome to you, the learner.
Today, we are looking at a truly fascinating primary source. Yeah, this one is really something.
It's a point in time briefing document prepared for the UK government's HMRC Data Science Academy.
For those who don't know, that's Her Majesty's revenue and customs. So basically, the UK's
tax payment and customs authority, and the document is dated May 9, 2026, which means we are looking
at a snapshot of a massive like critical infrastructure organization grappling with a complete
technological earthquake. Exactly. And our mission today is to cut straight through the vendor hype.
We are going to look at how a highly regulated insanely high stakes environment is actually
evaluating and deploying AI coding assistance. Right, because the stakes don't get much higher
than national tax infrastructure. No, they don't. And just to set the stage here, we are looking at
this strictly through a technical and organizational lens. We are not taking any political stances
on government operations. We are simply unpacking the technical realities from this briefing to
understand where software engineering is really heading. Because one thing is absolutely clear here,
we have moved way, way beyond simple auto complete. The real challenge for software engineering has
completely shifted. It really has. I mean, the shift between 2024 and 2026 is just foundational.
We are no longer talking about a better predictive text engine for programmers. To understand the
operational nightmare HMRC is trying to manage. We first have to understand the mechanics of what
these tools are actually doing now. We've moved away from isolated single file code suggestions.
Okay, let's unpack this because the mechanical distance is huge. In the past, you'd be typing
a single line of code in one specific file. And the AI would basically guess the rest of the line
based on the characters right before it. Like a super smart auto complete on your phone.
Exactly. It was completely blind to the rest of your project. But now we are talking about full
code based context and what the briefing calls, agentic edits. What's fascinating here is that
agentic edits mean systems capable of multi file autonomous editing. They're not just generating
an isolated patch of text anymore. They are executing command and test loops. And how are they
doing that mechanically? Mechanics wise, they are using MCP, which is the model context protocol.
Yes, exactly. MCP is a crucial piece of the puzzle. It allows the AI to interface
directly with external tools, local file systems, and data sources. So the AI can read an error log
in your terminal, decide to open three different files, rewrite a function, run your test suite,
see that it failed, and then rewrite the function again, based on the new error.
Wow. I love the analogy that comes to mind for this. The old AI was essentially a fancy
spell checker. It was entirely reactive. It waited for you to type. But this new AI is acting like
a junior, but insanely fast team member. It can independently inspect a repository, sketch out a
plan, execute the code, revise its own work, and ultimately draft a pull request or a PR for you
to review. It sounds like a dream for a developer. But if you are the head of security or operations
for a government tax authority, it is terrifying. I can imagine because every single new capability
creates a completely new governance surface. If the AI can interface with your terminal,
you have to establish rules for that terminal. Yeah, think about the permissions nightmare.
If this fast junior developer is a machine, what is it allowed to read? Like, can it read your live
customer database, which would be a disaster, total disaster? And what does it allow to write?
Can it fetch a random software package from the external internet just to solve a problem?
What terminal commands can it run? Every one of those actions requires a logging mechanism
and a control point. And the vendor claims around autonomy are changing so fast that any claim
needs to be time stamped. Like, what an AI could do in January is completely different from what
it can do in May. Wait, wait, wait, I have to push back on the core premise here. Yeah,
because I find this a little hard to believe. Oh, really? How so? Well, if these tools are
getting so smart, and they can do all these multi file edits running test loops in seconds,
like a hyper caffeinated junior dev, then engineering teams must be getting massively faster. I mean,
that is the whole pitch, right? But the evidence we are looking at in this document paints a very
different picture. It really does. You're telling me an engineer with this super tool might actually
be slowing down. How does that make sense? That paradox is a it's probably one of the most critical
insights in this entire deep dive. Let's look at the productivity reality check here. We have
two very different studies in the briefing to illustrate the contrast. Back in 2023,
there's a really famous co pilot study that found meaningful measurable speed games for
developers. But and correct me if I'm wrong, those games were on highly constrained, well-specified
tasks, right? Like green field development, exactly, starting from scratch in a perfectly
controlled environment where you just asked the AI to, you know, write a function that sorts this
list spot on. Now, fast forward to a 2025 field study conducted by M E T R. They put early 2025
AI tools in the hands of experienced open source maintainers. Okay. And these maintainers were
working in mature brown field repositories, brown field, meaning older, established code bases,
right? Code bases packed with legacy systems, weird workarounds, you know, massive technical debt,
things they already knew well. And the result, the experienced maintainers were actually slower on
average when using the AI tools than when they just wrote the code themselves. Wow, slower. If you
are a senior dev listening to this right now, you have probably felt that exact pain of untangling a
junior engineer spaghetti code. Oh, absolutely. Now, imagine the junior engineer types 1000 words
a minute. The briefing notes that the biggest hidden cost of AI is not the code generation itself.
The code is basically free. Yeah. The hidden cost is the checking, correcting, and integrating of
those outputs. Because the psychological and cognitive load of reading someone else's code is
entirely different from writing it yourself. Yeah. When you write code, you're building a mental
model of the logic line by line. But when an AI just dumps 50 lines of code into your file,
you have to reverse engineer its logic to figure out if it actually accounts for all the weird
edge cases in your legacy system. Let's break down exactly how this fails in practice, because
the failure modes mentioned in the document are fascinating. One major issue they highlight is
overbroad edits. Yeah, where it changes way more files than it needs to. Exactly. And then there's
dependency drift. Say the AI hits an error while trying to build a feature. Instead of like fixing
the core logic, it autonomously decides to pull in a random third party library from the internet
that patches the error, which is a huge security risk. Huge. Now your secure government tax portal
relies on an unsupported package maintained by one guy in the browser. The human reviewer has to
catch that. Another massive failure mode is what happens with testing. The AI is often tasked with
writing the feature and the unit tests for that feature. And this can lead to tests that pass
for the entirely wrong reason. Wait, how does that work? Well, the AI hallucinates a piece of logic.
And then it writes a test that perfectly validates its own hallucination. It mocks out the wrong data
layer, or it ignores the actual database constraints, creating a sort of self-fulfilling prophecy.
Oh, that is insidious. Right. The green checkmark appears. AI says it succeeded, but the code is
fundamentally broken. Another one is the brittle use of external tools. The AI might rate a script
that relies on a specific version of a command line tool. And if your server has a different version,
it all crashes. So when you add up the time it takes a veteran engineer to hunt down these
subtle workflow failures, any productivity gains you made by not typing the syntax just evaporate.
They're completely gone. And here's where it gets really interesting. Because these hidden costs are
entirely centered around checking and correcting, the fundamental bottleneck in software engineering
has physically moved. It is no longer about sitting at a keyboard and manually translating logic into
syntax. The new bottleneck is validation and approval. And the market has totally realized this.
The enterprise vendors are actively responding to that shifted bottleneck. Nobody is just selling a
quote unquote code generator anymore. They are selling governance bundles. The market is converging
on packages that combine a coding assistant, an autonomous agent, and a review workflow into one
product. So for an organization like HMRC, the decisive question is no longer which model is best,
but rather which workflow can we govern? Exactly. And the expert briefing categorizes the market to
help with exactly that. At the absolute bottom layer, you have your IDE autocomplete tools,
things like Gemini codices or early GitHub co-pilot. They live purely in your text editor.
And the risk there is relatively low. Very low. But then you step up to repo level or terminal
agents like Claude code or cursor agent. These have mechanical access to your file system. They
can read your whole repository and they can execute shell commands. So the risk profile jumps
significantly. Oh, massively. Above that, you have PR and review assistance. Tools like Windsor
for Devin review that integrate directly into your version control platform to review pull
requests before they get merged. Right. Then you hit fully autonomous software engineering agents
that claim they can resolve tickets start to finish. And finally, sitting on top of all of this are
enterprise and government control layers designed to put fences around all these agents, which brings
us to how an organization actually evaluates these tools. If you look at standard AI benchmarks,
you will see a lot of talk about SWE bench. Right. SWE bench is useful for tracking the
capability ceiling of a model. It tests what the smartest AI can do in a vacuum on a specific
isolated problem. I kind of think it has to be events like a spelling bee. A spelling bee,
I like that. Yeah, it proves the AI knows the dictionary. Yeah. But for an enterprise environment
for HMRC, a spelling bee isn't enough. They rely on something called code scale bench,
because code scale bench is more relevant for the enterprise. It stresses larger code bases and
tool traces. Yeah, it's more like testing. If the AI can write a coherent novel while three
other authors are actively editing the chapters, it tests the messy interconnected reality of
restricted enterprise environments. So the government question isn't whether the AI can
write a script that passes a test. The question is whether it can be deployed without completely
undermining established security and change management controls. Precisely. Let's get really
practical here. If governance is the new bottleneck, how do you actually put a leash on a terminal
executing agent? Like if I give an AI permission to run shell commands so it can build my project,
how do you stop it from accidentally dropping a production database or pasting a highly sensitive
API key to the open internet? This raises an important question, and it is where the HMRC
briefing offers a brilliant, truly elegant solution. They outline specific operational
guardrails, but the core mechanism is something called the ageness.md file. Oh, I am obsessed with
this concept. The mechanics of it are so smart is basically a simple markdown file,
like an instruction manual that lives right inside your version control system sitting next to your
actual code. Right. And every single time the AI agent boops up to work on your repository,
the system forces it to read the agents.md file before it is allowed to execute a single line
of code. It acts as a localized policy engine. You are dictating the operating constraints for
that specific project. The file clearly outlines the purpose of the assistant, but more importantly,
it strictly defines the boundaries. It explicitly lists the allowed commands. So mechanically,
if the AI decides it wants to run, say, npm published to push a package to the public internet,
but the agents.md file only lists test, length, format, and type check under the allowed commands.
The AI parses that file realizes the action is out of bounds and just stops itself.
That is so clean. And you combine that with a list of forbidden commands. You explicitly write
down that deployment commands, destructive shell commands, and accessing the production
credentials directory are strictly prohibited. The AI system prompt is weighted heavily to obey
this local file above its own general instincts. The briefing also takes us a step further by
defining what tasks are actually safe to give an AI in a government setting. Right, because
not all tasks are created equal. Exactly. Safe tasks are things that are easily verifiable by a human,
generating unit tests for existing code, updating documentation, drafting release notes, or PR
summarization over synthetic or sanitized corpora, generating boilerplate structures is another good
one. And then you contrast that with the absolute, do not touch zones, the tasks to avoid at all costs.
You do not let an AI initiate privileged infrastructure changes. You do not let it execute
operations on production databases. And crucially, for HMRC, you keep it entirely away from high
sensitivity case work logic, which makes perfect sense. I mean, if you have 1000 lines of code
that dictate the specific formulas for how a citizen's tax burden is calculated, you absolutely
cannot have an AI hallucinate a more efficient algorithm that accidentally alters the tax code.
No, that would be a nightmare. Business logic is human territory. Boilerplate code is machine
territory. Yes, exactly. So what does this all mean? We've seen the risks and the rules.
Now, let's look at the ultimate conclusion of this briefing. What a successful governed AI
workflow actually looks like in practice for the civil service. The briefing grounds this in a
really concrete repo anchored case study. And what stands out about this case study is that it isn't,
you know, flashy vendor video demo of an AI typing code at lightning speed. It's not a generic AI
wrote this claim. The output of the pilot wasn't just the software it built. It was an
auditable postmortem of human and AI contributions. Yeah, it was a prototype where a human specified
the task severely constrained the environment using those agents as MD rules we just talked
about, and then exported the evidence of exactly how the code came to be. The evidence part is key.
Oh, absolutely. If we connect this to the bigger picture, that phrase exported the evidence
is the beating heart of this entire document. It leads to the strongest anchor line in the
briefing. They say, for government, provenance is not an optional add on to AI output. Providence
is part of the product. Providence is part of the products. Let's dig into what that actually
means mechanically. Providence is the origin story of your code. Right. It is not enough that the
code compiles and the app runs. You have to be able to cryptographically prove how it was written,
why certain logic decisions were made, and who human or machine actually made them.
Because if a tax calculation fails three years from now, auditors need to look back and see the
exact trace of the AI agent proposing the code, and the specific human engineer who reviewed and
approved it. This represents a monumental shift in the nature of engineering labor. We are basically
watching the role of a software engineer evolve in real time. We really are. The labor is shifting
aggressively from manual syntax production towards steering, architectural review, mathematical proof,
and governance, which means the way an organization measures the success of its engineers, or when
polluting these tools, it has to change immediately. The document issues a massive warning against
surveying developers and just asking them if they felt faster using the tools. Oh, yeah. Feeling
faster is such a psychological trap. Right. I mean, it feels great to watch an AI write 200 lines
of code in four seconds. But feeling faster doesn't mean you are actually shipping, secure,
working code of production any quicker. No, not at all. To cut through that illusion,
HMRC is advised to measure hard operational metrics. You measure cycle time. How long it
takes an idea to actually reach production. You measure first past test success. You track the
rework rate rework rate being like how much of the AI's code did the human have to delete or rewrite?
Exactly. And most importantly, you measure escape defects and security findings. Because if you write
code 10 times faster, but introduced 10 times as many bugs, you haven't actually gained anything.
No, you've just automated the creation of technical debt. And the language we use to talk about these
tools is just as critical as the metrics. The briefing provides explicit vocabulary guidance.
They strongly advise teams to use terms like assistant or agent. And they completely and
totally reject the industry hype term autonomous developer. Because the rejection of that phrase
isn't just about semantics. It is about legal and operational reality. Autonomous developer
is a great marketing pitch. But in a government setting, it actively obscures where accountability
sits. Accountability must always legally and operationally remain with human people and human
teams. Right. You simply cannot delegate legal or security liability to a Python script.
You really can. So to bring this all together for you listening, we started this deep dive with
the common assumption that AI coding tools, we're just going to act like a magical cruise control,
making everyone type code 10 times faster. But what we have discovered,
looking through the lens of this 2026 HMRC briefing, is that these agent tools are fundamentally
reshaping the entire software development lifecycle. It is no longer a typing competition. It is a
complex game of risk management, rigorous review, and strict governance. And whether you are managing
an enterprise development team, or you are just trying to stay informed on how your own workflow
is going to change over the next few years, the central takeaway is unavoidable. Adopting AI
successfully is not about subscribing to the smartest language model. No, it's not. It is
entirely about building the most governable, audible workflow. It is about proving your work
every single time. But before we wrap up, there's a final provocative thought I want to leave you with.
Something to mull over or explore on your own that builds on this massive shift we've discussed
today. Let's hear it. Well, we know that the engineering labor of today is shifting away from
manually writing code and shifting almost entirely towards reviewing, steering, and governing AI
outputs. Right, we've established that. But if that is true, how will the next generation of
junior developers ever build the deep foundational intuition they need to actually spot the AI's
subtle mistakes and legacy systems? Think back to the M ETR study we talked about earlier.
Those senior developers were able to spot the insidious mistakes because they had spent a
decade in the trenches writing that bad code themselves. They had the muscle memory of making
mistakes. That's a really good point. If the AI does all the heavy lifting early on,
who teaches the human reviewers how to govern these hyperfast systems tomorrow? When the
cruise control suddenly decides to reroute your car into a brick wall, will anyone in the driver's
seat still possess the muscle memory to grab the steering wheel. Something to think about.